[Music]
all right tomorrow night's GOP Primary
debate will be hosted by our sister
Network the Fox Business Network so of
course the economy will be front and
center in fact look at this 46 percent
of GOP Primary voters in the latest Fox
Business poll now say the economy is the
most important issue so-called
biodynamics not going well for most
Americans latest NBC News poll showing
72 percent of Americans saying they are
dissatisfied with the economy not a good
number now taking the stage tomorrow
night will be Rhonda Santos Nikki Haley
the fake ramaswamy Tim Scott Mike Pence
Chris Christie and of course Doug burgum
will be on there as well as our two
colleagues Stuart Varney and Dana Perino
who are serving as the uh debate
moderator Steiner joins us now from the
Reagan Library in beautiful Simi Valley
with a preview Dana how are you
look uh Sean I'm great I know that
you've been out here before it's a
beautiful local shin and
to have a debate tomorrow night
uh totally agree
um I don't know if you've hosted a
debate before but nope uh I think you're
gonna be great and I think there's a lot
to talk about I mean usually we're told
the peace and prosperity Drive elections
61 percent of Americans live in paycheck
to paycheck I would imagine that's going
to have an impact on the election your
thoughts it's very interesting that do
remember of course in 1980 President
Reagan for that election his campaign
slogan was are you better off today than
you were four years ago and presidential
candidates have used that ever since
when they're challenging the incumbent
and today the ABC Washington Post poll
from two days ago say that today that
number is the lowest it has been since
they started asking the question so as
you mentioned in your open President
Biden is a is he's in a terrible
terrible weekend position as an
incumbent so the Republicans do have an
opportunity but I do think they have to
get a little bit more specific than they
have in the past Sean and in this debate
we intend to press them on how they
would make the economic conditions
better in the country as quickly as
possible for people who are really
feeling it
so much of this to me is rooted in
energy you know when out back up to four
dollars an average for a gallon of
gasoline costs more to heat and cool
your home every product every American
Buys in every store they go to now costs
more because of the higher shipping
costs associated with it you know to me
this is like a self-inflicted wound that
wound this all of this is unnecessary
the Border chaos is unnecessary economic
Energy prices unnecessary these are all
policies that he's pushed and he's
implemented and it's having a huge
impact on Society at large and yet
they're bragging about it they're saying
combinomics I'm not sure if that's gonna
we'll come back to bite them or not I
would think it will
I think it was I think that this Summer
that they tried that and then
unfortunately for them they aren't stuck
in this position where they'll say three
things one they'll say that biodynamics
is working you just don't understand it
yet right how condescending can that be
then they'll say the border is closed
the border is fine well that's clearly
not true and Sean as an issue that one
is creeping up higher and higher in
terms of concerns both for republicans
and Democrats the third thing they'll
say is nobody at the White House can
keep up with Joe Biden he's so energetic
and Youthful no one's buying that either
so you have three of their main issue
areas that people say they are most
concerned about it's as something that
they actually can't answer and so uh one
of the challenges for these Republican
candidates tomorrow night though is all
about everybody on stage thinks that
they would be a better president than
Joe Biden and they think they would be a
pres better president than former
president Trump now how do they break
out of that pack president Trump's lead
is so commanding it is seemingly
enduring one of these people needs to
have a breakout moment tomorrow night so
that they can say I should be the main
rival to president Trump in this contest
so I expect some fireworks possibly some
aggression but I hope to lighten it up a
little bit as well
uh I like to lighten it up part we
always need a little humor in every
situation all right how do you deal with
the audience getting out of control how
do you deal with the candidates just not
listening to their your time is up I
mean that always becomes you know a
needle you gotta threat if you're the
moderator
I know that Stuart Varney and I
opportunity to be on television together
because of you and we did a hit every
Tuesday night together on your show and
it really helped us form a great
friendship and he's got that terrific
British accent and I told him I'm going
to make sure that he is helping me keep
control of the room because everybody
will listen to a British accent like
that Dana thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else